six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's try the eight one
three area code caller from eight one
three go ahead hello
yeah go ahead hi I'm Grayson I'm from
the Berkeley area and my question is
that given the Anthony Kennedy
retirement announcement yes how in
danger do you think that the Oberg or
virgin fella V Hodges decision is if I
keep hearing that it's not in danger
it's a federal decision right but I
think that overly optimistic I think it
is so that that's the case that said
that unless I'm confusing my cases which
would not be the first time but that's
the case that said that states can't ban
same-sex marriage we're on the same page
right that's correct yeah I think that
roe v wade is more immediately in peril
than the court's June 2015 ruling on
same-sex marriage at the state level but
I think it is overly optimistic to say
that there is no way whatsoever to
revisit or to because remember it's all
precedent right that's the point so the
court wouldn't be able to go back to a
June 2015 decision and say we we
overturn a prior decision but the way
that this works when you get this type
of judicial activism going is that you
start new lawsuits around the issue at
lower courts and you continue appealing
appealing appealing until eventually you
can get something to the Supreme Court
that by virtue of ruling on they could
overturn precedent and that's kind of
like the de-facto way it would happen I
share your concern Grayson I think that
everything is on the table once you
replace Anthony Kennedy with an
ideologue all right thank you very much
appreciate the call yeah Barry I mean
this we're if you have a feeling we're
gonna be talking about this for a very
long time and tomorrow on the show we're
going to talk about Jeffrey Toobin
saying he predicts 20 states banning
abortion within a year and a half yeah
which is horrifying I'm not looking
forward to all of this maybe a rough
time in our history on this this is more
than just interesting material for shows
right this is genuinely a disaster